- Welcome to Sober History.
Today's guest is my dear
friend Eric Falconer.
First subject is called having a dick.
It doesn't suck having a dick?
- No I love having a dick.
(laughing)
- [Derek] That's my favorite line.
- I love it.
- [Derek] There's a lot of things I love,
but nothing more than having a dick.
- I'd have a dick all day
- [Derek] Having a dick all day
- If I could
I'm scared about what
I'm about to say here.
I'm really scared.
I had a girlfriend once in high school
she knew I liked the movie
Beauty and the Beast.
(laughing)
so she gave me a statue
of Belle as a gift.
It was beautiful, it
was a little statuette,
porcelain or whatever you make them out of
of Belle from Beauty and the Beast.
- [Derek] Beautiful.
- It was beautiful, it was french
- [Derek] Gaston
- A french gift
I was an awesome boyfriend by the way
- You were what?
- An awesome boyfriend by the way
- You accepted the gift though?
- I did and I didn't talk about it
for another 20 years (laughing)
- Then you brought you
up the Statue of Liberty
You remember play dough?
- Yeah I don't remember how
I started eating play dough.
It's the gist of the arm man.
If you care about
America you will see this
for what it's meant to be.
- The Smurf dick.
- It looks like a Gremlin, it
doesn't look like a statue.
- You know how you said
as a kid I'd do right now,
fucking eat play dough, I
loved eating play dough.
- Alright so you talked me into it
Eating it?
- I had a thing as a kid
I would eat paste, I would eat paper,
I would eat like notebooks.
- I get paste, you would eat play dough?
- Mmmhmm
This is old school Miley
- It's fucking terrible
It was the saltiest thing I've
ever put in my mouth, ever.
- Wig it down with some wine
- How did I not puke there?
You'd think that would
have been my puking moment.
Stay tuned for more Drunk History.